wow wait this black people would add her
cowboys people still say that
everybody who comes to my rodeo i change
their mind i change their lives and
we're excited about changing the
narrative and we work every day towards
that
tom the cowboys we're a crew of lifelong
friends who grew up in the original
farms here in compton california we all
have a love for animals love for nature
we ride horses
we all came together in this non-profit
that was founded by my aunt back in 1988
what compton was like at that time is
the reason why this ranch actually
exists it's a solution to what the
problems were
the reason i started black world
championship rodeo is the white rodeos
excluded us
there was a conscious effort to downplay
and eliminate the contributions to black
americans to the american experience but
once we got black world championship
rodeo going i invited everybody to come
participate
there's not a part of my life that i can
remember not having horses
so this is goldie this is my big boy
he's a rare color shade of champagne
gold there's not that many horses out
there like that camden's always been a
very beautiful place growing up it was
always very community oriented was just
the the dark side was really dark
what's going to be my weapon of choice
to fight against the streets like
it's going to be my mouthpiece it's
gonna my brains are gonna be the books
because the magic and the appeal of the
horse is so strong the kids end up being
like man i do whatever i gotta take to
ride so you know you can start going to
school you getting your grades right and
show that to the next generation
create that cycle it's what it takes to
grow a community you got to have that
constant give back and put an output on
my great great grandfather was a buffalo
soldier when i was two years old my
father put me on a horse that was used
for the plowing these are threads of a
culture
having that responsibility of shedding
light on the culture and the history and
the legacy that we that has been laid by
our people for many centuries and has
not had the opportunity to show itself
that's our constant mission always
i view myself as more than a cowboy i
view myself as someone who can work hard
and create ideas and institutions that
can survive
randy i wanted to ask how much does it
cost to upkeep the ranch and how are you
paying for everything you get a lot of
great support from the community so we
have our nonprofit set up so we get a
lot of great direct donations from
people like including recently dr dre
donated a year's worth of funding for
horse feet companies hire us to do
commercials billboards and then we sell
t-shirts hats all this stuff between all
of that helps us pay bills i built this
for everybody the black rodeo was built
for everybody and all the doubting
thomases that said to me there are no
black cowboys they never did anything
they are now all on the button moot
it's important for the kids to see
people that look like them i mean the
big vision is to taking our model and
being able to potentially replicate it
in other cities that need it the best
thing that i can do for our youngsters
is they have to see me as a role model i
don't need to lecture them
they need to see what i can do
when you have the kids excited on their
own to go to the program that's the
biggest value you fight with so our kids
wake up and beg their parents to come
here so we're already winning because
they want to change and they want to do
it
[Music]
hey thanks for watching bloomberg quick
take now subscribe to our channel to see
the biggest stories the moment they
happen from around the world and tune in
to our 24 7 live stream for global news
coverage documentaries interviews deep
dives and shows on the stories that you
care most about